well Tanika forgive me I don't know too
much about the option process so I think
you've said before that the option
process is just the right to sort of not
take up your time but work with you and
tie up the script yeah they don't even
always when you get an option it's
almost I guess the best way to say it
it's like selling your script for a
period of time
so you're there optioning it with the
right to completely purchase it so
usually when there's an option it's
let's say five thousand or ten thousand
dollars for a year or two and they and
you can't do anything with that script
during that time and you're not
necessarily working with them either
you're just saying go off do whatever
you want to do and if you get the money
for the script then you guys have
already agreed how much you're going to
be paid for that script so let's say
you're gonna be paid $100,000 for the
script and the option is $10,000
well that's $10,000 against the price of
the sale of the script so when the
script actually sells you'll get 90
because you already got 10 okay and
let's say a year the option expires in a
year or two years or whatever it is and
they can't they haven't been able to get
the money for it or get it set up or
packaged or anything and they don't
really want to work with it anymore
because they feel like they can't then
the script rights revert back to you so
then you can do whatever you want to do
with it or someone else can do what they
want to do with it as opposed to someone
saying no I love this I believe I just
want to buy it outright so when you're
contacted about optioning scripts is
that something that you've already
initiated or you you got obviously put
it out somewhere or people are seeing it
you can shop it around where is that
place um usually as far as an option
it can happen a lot of different ways
like you can meet someone and tell them
about your story or script and they are
super interested and then they want to
read the script and then they decide to
option it or you can be super proactive
and find some production companies that
are looking for material and have your
manager
or somebody submit a letter or an email
letter and email and see if they'll read
it and you know it's like usually you're
sending like a synopsis or a one-liner
or something like that and then if they
do they might decide to option it
there's still the contest route I mean
there are a lot of amazing contests out
there that literally start careers I
mean the most famous one is the Nichols
fellowship that's like twenty five
thousand dollars and a lot of publicity
is the most prestigious screenwriting
award you can get then of course the
Sundance lab which nurtures your project
and nurtures you and really helps as
much as they can help you take it to the
next level and maybe get it made there's
no money in that one but there is a lot
of prestige and and they you know they
mother hand you a little bit so that's
great it's nice and then there's there's
a few others out there that have like a
decent money prize connected to it and
it's a really great way for your manager
or agent or somebody like that to sort
of platform somebody to read your stuff
anything do's and don'ts let's suppose
you know someone that's getting
something optioned is the first time
mm-hmm any any things that they just
need to be aware of but they might not
yeah I would say really be aware of the
fine print sometimes um there'll be
something in the option where they can
just automatically auction your script
again for another year and I would make
sure that that's not in there and if it
is make sure that it's in there but with
a price tag right for another twenty
five hundred or something like that and
make sure that you're getting everything
some people will just say well I just
want let's just keep it simple make it a
one page just the option for this but
really with an option you should get as
many details and that option as possible
so if you want to be a producer or if
you want a certain credit you should
have all of that stuff in your option
because if they do you know get the
money or whatever the negotiations
different so this is when you have your
power at the option level is when you
have your power you can say well ok you
I want an associate producer credit so
you need to put that in the option when
you get your money that I'm still gonna
get my associate producer credit because
then that's something that they have to
deal with when they're out there in the
world you know ok if it is a deal
breaker for you to be the director then
you need to tell them that right up
front and it needs to be part of you
know your a yeah it just needs to be you
know if it's a deal breaker doesn't have
to be if it is you know and do you have
a lawyer look this over or if you have a
trusted friend I mean if you have a
really good manager they often serve as
the kind of lawyer oakerson
Oh a really good manager has the skills
to look at a contract like that and know
what should and shouldn't be in it it's
great if you have a lawyer but I
wouldn't spend money to have a lawyer do
it you should have your manager really
you know do that and hopefully it's a
good manager and they can protect you in
that way right yeah so then when they go
back to option something a second and
third time it's pretty much the same
deal but you're getting if this is part
of the agreement you're getting that
extra chunk of money and then it locked
it yeah and sometimes it can be more
like I've definitely gotten more money
because they're keeping it for a long
I'm like well you've had this for a year
you couldn't get anything going with it
so if I'm gonna have my project locked
up then you need to give me a little bit
more money for another year so you can
sort of up the ante a bit and and
they'll go for it especially if they
really feel passionate about it and like
they might be close so then if they
decide to actually go ahead with it then
whatever the option money you were paid
is then taken out of that final usually
it's taken out of it so you know if
somebody really believes that they're
close and really believes in the script
and they're like okay I've had it for a
year I just need one more year I'm right
there they shouldn't have any problems
with just go ahead and paying a little
extra because it's gonna come out of the
check anyway
sure sure they're not losing anything
right it's the same deal you just taking
I'm just getting some of my money now
versus later
that you think that you're gonna sell
this good and so if they decide then
let's suppose they have optioned to
three times they're going to pass so now
the rights revert back to you and you
own it again and you own it again okay
but you've kept that much and you keep
and you keep the money come on yeah okay
so it's not a bad do you know you know I
actually have no job I the door I say is
like I made the most money for a script
that was never made into a movie I
probably made about seventy seventy five
thousand dollars over a period of time
of a jar by the door in contests and
options and all that stuff and and I'd
love to make it into a movie so yeah but
it's also spawned something else but it
spawned something else so hey I'll take
that trade-off
you